[موسيقى]
من الصيني الى الاردن جدل عالمي ومحلي بعد
رصد فيديوهات لاغنام تدور حول نفسها ظاهره
حيرت الخبراء والمختصين وتحليلات طبيه
وسلوكيه وفلكيه حتى وصل الامر للدينيه
[موسيقى]
باختصار شديد وزاره الزراعه الاردنيه
حاله مرضيه ناتجه عن وجود ديدان في دماغ
الحيوان تجعله يدور حول نفسه هذا راي
الاطباء البيطريين اذن فالحيوانات برايهم
ليست سليمه كما قالت وزاره الزراعه راي
طبي قطع الشك باليقين ايضا بشان تفسيرات
وتحليلات ضجه بها مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
فمنها من ذهب الى انها ظواهر فلكيه واخونا
قالوا انها من علامات قيام الساعه الامر
الذي استدعى تدخل دائره الافتاء العامه
لبحثها فاجابت لا علاقه لهذه الظاهره باي
دلالات دينيه
[موسيقى]
هذا ما يسمى بالمرياع كبش يحمل مواصفات
خاصه جعلت منه قائد للقطيع ان حدث وسار
بشكل دائري فالجميع على خطاه سمعا وطاعه
للمريض
اسرار كثيره تقف وراء عالم الحيوان وسلوك
قد لا يفسره الانسان فلله في خلقه شؤون